now what you need to understand is that
it starts with us men
[Music]
there is a huge attack on the normal
healthy family structure parents spoke
out at a school board meeting hearing
about per child's class being showed a
movie with a gay character in it they
want to make men more feminine and they
want to make women more masculine it's a
view that celebrates destructive and
toxic behavior and hurts so many your
perceptions of the truth doesn't change
the truth itself they have identified 31
gender identities think how crazy this
world will become
they want you to be confused about what
it means to be a good man
you know a lot of people are falling for
this